the barbaric murder of keen mulready
woods has stunned Ireland in the
teenagers hometown of Drogheda they
United in opposition to gangland crime
political leaders setting election
campaign differences aside to support
those demanding an end to the violence
people recognized that a some kind of
threshold of decency if that was ever a
threshold has been crossed it was bad
enough the situation where a young boy
was killed but then the mutilation of
his body whatever that meant it has
really caused people in Drori and I'm
sure for our fields to want to know what
was that all about
what was the point of such a barbaric
act the victims limbs were find in a
sports bag on this housing estate his
head in a burnt-out car the body of the
17 year old dismembered to intimidate a
rival gang Irish police are still
investigating reports the murder was
filmed on a smartphone by ruthless
criminals recruiting what one veteran
crime correspondent calls child soldiers
and it is quite worrying for the future
because this is happening in every town
in Ireland that the other young kids
been groomed interesting it's it's the
dynamic the people who are involved at
teens and 20 year olds chaotic young men
who create chaos around them live
chaotic lives and end their lives end
prematurely Phillip became a drug addict
and dealer at the age of 14 he says
young man enticed by the trappings of
crime need a miracle when you're so
young involved in it and you get a taste
that of money and you get a taste of the
power as a young boy and you're drawn to
people who you see as have made it so
it's a tremendous power that takes over
your life and it's nearly like you're
addicted to the whole loose thought the
break out of it is nearly impossible
this community is sending a message not
just to those who sell drugs but to
those who buy them cocaine use is a trek
levels in Ireland and it's that
unprecedented demand that's fueling such
violence between suppliers they want a
multi-agency approach from their next
government resources for addiction
services and for police tackling the
gangs still striking fear across Ireland
David Blevins Sky News in Drogheda